[Música]
también pasa
bueno básicamente les voy a contar lo
que les explica es el rato y yo era un
niño normal en la ciudad de mexico
público de una vecindad donde la
paquetería y me trajeron entonces a una
madre que en este caso y tuvo algunos
problemas nuncio de mi papá fue el
clásico que estudió hasta donde pudo
trabajo siempre hasta donde pudo y
esfuerzo ha sido un trabajo todo de
repente hicieron la planta no sea la
madre que hace que hace trabajo que era
bastante grande yo tenía 42 43 años ya
se ha decidido sin encontrar un trabajo
y en este caso no como que muy bien
planificado nunca se preparó para algo
así entonces mi mamá es de un pueblo en
la sierra norte de puebla
podemos salir para allá porque
supuestamente la vida era más barato era
más fácil obtener ingresos para poder
vivir en la forma cómoda pero no fue tan
sencillo entonces básicamente me hablaba
mucho sobre cómo se había tenido que
esforzar para obtener lo que había
tenido y la decepción que él sentía por
parte del sistema de decir o sea me
esforcé 30 años de vivir estudiando
trabajando chingando löw de repente no
tengo
entonces básicamente lo que tú
esfuérzate haz tus cosas no permitas que
alguien más tome las decisiones sobre tu
horario de trabajo sobre los ingresos
que tienes no seas un medio que no te
des puedes hasta los 30 años para poder
39 trabajar para poder jubilarse no te
compras una casa de infonavit tu símbolo
para ser el dueño de tu vida solamente
depende de ti porque básicamente lo que
se ven en la imagen es lo que nos pasa a
todos o sea somos jóvenes la mayoría
ustedes universitarios también ponen
mucho tiempo tiene mucha energía pero la
mayoría no tiene mucho dinero como para
poder hacer lo que les gusta una vez que
entras a la vida laboral hablamos de 25
30 y 35 años tienes mucho dinero mucha
energía priego utilizada de tiempo
precisamente por eso trabajas que 50 a
60 horas a la semana pasa tras 20 horas
a la semana entran suerte que tiempo te
queda para ti para hacer lo que a ti te
gusta prácticamente nada
yo vine terminan siendo de alguien de 60
años que ya trabajó detiene su casa y ya
tiene su carro tiene todo pero cuánta
energía te quedas realmente cuántas
ganas tienes de hacer las cosas que en
tu juventud reservas
básicamente toda la presentación se basa
en imágenes de los volúmenes cosas así
son más o menos de sobrado así que se
imaginaran dos porque ahora sí
nunca han visto esa tarta de la película
de rock urbano donde surge la
reclamación no sólo por ti
básicamente todas las excepciones
ni siquiera el punto es que tanto eres
capaz de resistir luego y seguir
avanzando porque muchas veces nos
quedamos al vacío si hablamos de la
chica yo en un partido me mentiría
porque no me va a apoyar o yo no puedo
seguir en mi carrera porque igual me
sacás no me daban y al menos desde mi
perspectiva acción es una tontería o sea
a partir de suerte a todo lo que nos
pase es nuestra responsabilidad
completamente indirectas de si vas
ignacio es pobre no es tu culpa sino las
propias y lo es básicamente se trata de
social la duda te va poner cuantas
trabas de imagínese y unas y debe ser
capaz de superarlas y aquí es donde yo
les voy a empezar un poco habla un poco
más sobre mi juventud por así decirlo
sea ya les habló de la parte de viena
rancho que conectaba me hablaba sobre
ese tipo de cosas y yo quería más osado
llamado rey está en un rancho sea
liberal era para todas las 5 de la
mañana ayer ordeñar las vacas y después
a las 7 la secundaria regresar a las 3
ir a cuidar a los animales cortar pasto
para el ganado y alimentarte dormir a
las 9 de la noche el bastante aburrido
de 8 al menos para mí entonces lo
querían más con actores en más si no
tenía el apoyo de prácticamente nadie o
sea mi papá trabajaba por temporadas a
veces no había como que mucho de dónde
sacar a entonces a los 15-16 años decidí
pues me pueden devengar el pedo solo y
llegué a la ciudad de méxico con dos mil
pesos en la bolsa y una mochila de ropa
podrá parecer una tontería probablemente
la evasiva pero aún así yo lo considero
la adecuada porque yo quería más
y tuve que esforzarme trabaje de casi
cualquier cosa que se pueda imaginar que
sea legal y moral lavacarros vendió al
periódico y repartió adelante trabaja en
una farmacia abengoa película sala del
metro
trabajo trabajo
pero él sin embargo tenía que sacar para
comer y para
así que no esfuerzo ratos libres tratará
de seguir siguiendo de seguir
aprendiendo lo que no me gustaba ya no
puede seguir en una escuela normal no
termina en la propia de una forma normal
y 8 solamente arriba se me estresa ella
pero me puede seguir aprendiendo o sea
lo quería más yo no quería simplemente
quedarme con el estilo de vida que tenía
en ese momento
con 17 poco antes de cumplir los 18 como
me tocó la generación del 2000 proceder
en que entonces la selección estaba
delineantes bendito y nieto de un chico
ventas ya poder tener un primer trabajo
medio formal entonces con lo que puede
dar de ahí comprado herramienta y pues a
trabajar como electricista
empecé a ganar más ya me di cuenta que
realmente te pagan por lo que sabes
hacer una provocación total
si me aprendo sobre la misma algo de
repente yo no es que te transformas y va
teniendo un jefe sigue obteniendo que
iba a trabajar de lunes a sábado
prácticamente no tengo un tiempo para mí
no puedo decidir sobre qué quiero hacer
porque no tengo el capital para hacerlo
así que voy a intentar hacer algo igual
abrió mi propio negocio y me metí en el
negocio de energías renovables con por
una historia muy curiosa nunca me pasó
por la cabeza dedicarme a esto sea
literal me cayó del cielo simplemente un
amigo y un familiar me dijo tengo un
problema en mi rancho este tengo logros
la presenta muy lejos el estudio del
agua pero creo que mis horas están
regando la gasolina
y luego sobre paneles solares
una cotización una propuesta de las dos
horas yo estaba en mi celular buscando
piedra más instalaciones paneles solares
y la tercera o cuarta imagen que me
salió del diagrama de la instalación se
lo comenté a la persona que había
preguntado de luce la cotización aceptó
el proyecto en un día daniel lo que
ganaba en un mes
y haciendo algo que me gustaba desde
niño siempre me gusta la electricidad y
la mecánica
así que
si tus fuerzas para muchas trabas que te
pongan la vida puedes obtener bastantes
cosas
y esta gráfica bueno es saber que ese
pez y lo económico
no
básicamente es que la vendió barras pero
porcentaje de que es para centrar la
población sus ingresos a su pero cuanto
hagan el pre9 la 10% que van a menos y
así hasta el 100 por ciento y la mayoría
de las personas que terminan en un
universidades a licenciados o ingenieros
tiene un ingreso promedio que será de
unos 12 mil pesos al mes pues más o
menos sé qué punto de la gráfica se
encuentran está en aproximadamente
aproximadamente dentro del 55 a 65 por
ciento de la población con mayores
ingresos y aún así siguen siendo el bajo
o sea simplemente consideren que todos
aquí tienen el hecho de comprarse una
casa brain en un lago en una ghana
colonia grandecita a unos 100 120 metros
cuadrados de terreno unos 150 200 de
construcción fue precisamente una casa
si cuesta 2 millones de pesos
consideren que a una tasa de interés del
10 12% como la suelen tener los bancos
si la pagan a 20 años la casa les va a
terminar costando más del doble un gran
esos 4 millones de pesos entre 30 años
prácticamente todos sus sueldos deben
pagar la casa
o sea realmente tenemos muchos sueños
pero las metas no las metas sino la web
el que nos va a proveer la educación que
estamos teniendo es tubería terminé la
universidad sacar buenas sacar buenas
calificaciones obtengan trabajo en una
empresa desarrollo te haciendo la
empresa y no nos permitiría llevar la
vida que deseamos sin embargo es lo que
todos nos venden
el otro problema principalmente quiso de
aquí en méxico es la cantidad de horas
de trabajo que tienes que pasar en el
que es lo que les comenté hace ratos en
méxico pasamos más de 2.200 horas al año
en el trabajo
solo tiempo que es el país en el que más
horas se trabaja
realmente lo único que importa en la
vida - de las cosas más importantes que
yo considero es el tiempo porque si no
vuelve el trabajo no por tu sueldo neto
como tal sino por cuánto tiempo te estás
dando a tu trabajo para obtener ese
sueldo puedes pasarte 100 horas
trabajando y ganar un poco más que bien
que trabaja 50 con qué cara tú puedes
hacerle a esa persona yo tengo mejor
trabajo que tú no puedes va a ser
simplemente en el sueldo
y bueno básicamente esto lo que le
estaba comentando ellos están ahí
vendiendo su tiempo por unas monedas
esclavas de una máquina llamada la
empresa o nombre en sus sueños
muchas veces el trabajo al que uno
terminó llegando a un mes al que una
esperaba inclusive suelen equivocarse en
la carrera que uno escoge porque no se
en la carrera que tu papá te dijo que
tenías que estudiar la que tu familia te
dice esta es la que tienes que llevar
porque de esto hay mucho trabajo pero la
familia siempre es educado algo así y
muchas veces no toman en cuenta lo que a
nosotros nos interesa lo que nosotros
queremos hacer con nuestras vidas
terminamos haciendo las cosas para
cumplir las expectativas de otras
personas no las propias
básicamente es lo que está sin usted ya
positivas a las personas la mayoría de
las personas sólo ven la vida es una
perspectiva la mente es la que nos educa
con la que nos educan en nuestra casa en
nuestra familia muy pocas personas
tenemos no sé si llamarlo virtud porque
tampoco albano de ver la vida desde
diferentes perspectivas en mi caso fue
bueno fui un niño de ciudad después fue
un
y un poco más grande de 10 años de
rancho después de un adolescente de 16
años solo en una ciudad su perspectiva
es que la mayoría no tienen la
oportunidad de vivir la mayoría de las
personas se quedan simplemente en un
mismo ambiente entonces no podemos
experimentar más cosas no podemos llegar
realmente a conocer todo para tener una
decisión totalmente basada en lo que
nosotros sabemos
y esto lo que les comentaba acerca del
tiempo que desconocen a pepe mujica en
el paciente de 20 uruguay les ya no
compran nada completas compras con el
tiempo de tu bebé que te gasta está en
conseguir esa plata y lo cual es
comentarios de qué te sirve tener mucho
dinero si no tienes tiempo
así para creo que es una casa grande si
no tienes con quién estar en ella tienes
que estar presionado siempre por pagar
las tres del dinero de obtener más plata
de poder comprar más cosas de poder
aparentar que tenemos más para que los
demás se sientan bien con nosotros
porque se hablan
si realmente lo que importa es el tiempo
que pueda pasar haciendo lo k tito no
está
lo mismo no su progreso y sobre el
equipaje vivir como justo para que las
cosas no me aprueben la libertad
de qué te sirve tener un carro del año
si siempre vas a estar como el chisme de
la mensualidad en un pueblo donde vas a
disfrutar para que lo quieres entonces
es mejor llevar una vida haciendo lo que
a ti te gusta
en mi caso muy específico es como bueno
ya llegué a una etapa de mi vida donde
gracias al negocio de energías
renovables que inicié cuando éramos
joven de 18 años armando los paneles y
sobre todo tengo instalaciones mil en
sus instalaciones básicamente vivo de
rentas por así decirlo
a cercana la que ustedes tienen ya me
libre de esa preocupación de tener un
trabajo de obtener un horario
básicamente los imagino quiero trabajar
no veo y no hay nadie que me puedo decir
algo esa es una gran ventaja
y aquí es donde me gustaría preguntarles
ustedes son jóvenes también la gran
mayoría pero imaginen a su niño de 12 de
78 años que aún soñaba con ser
astronautas el bombero ser doctor ser
ingeniero armando robots lo que sea que
algunos lo pueden lograr como el que
acaba de pasar de la nasa de mis
respetos lo que me encanta de progresar
es así
pero duro ese niño a la persona que son
ahora al que se mata en la escuela
muchas veces en una carrera que ni
siquiera les agrada tanto que están
empezando a fastidiarse de ella porque
ya empiezan a ver como de cuando ya un
término de la carrera que sigue dando
puede trabajar haciendo que es una duda
que a todos nos surge y muchas veces por
el miedo de las personas que nos
metieron la idea de que tenemos que dar
una vida si no somos capaces de tomar la
decisión de decir bueno no no me gusta
esto voy a hacer otra cosa la media de
las personas no tienen el valor de
hacerlo y créanme es algo muy importante
la mayoría del éxito al menos desde mi
perspectiva no se ve tanto a
escala de esfuerzo o al talento que una
persona tenga sino el valor si no tienes
el valor de hacer las cosas de qué te
sirve saber hacerlo
prácticamente de nada o sea si no eres
capaz de soltar los paradigmas que
tienes de tu infancia con la educación
que tienes de meterte en problemas con
tus padres porque te vas a salir de la
escuadra de por qué dices bueno quiero
cambiar de carrera o que iba a ser este
track o se me olvida o cosas así no vas
a llegar a ningún lado simplemente vas a
ser una persona de 35-40 años en más
grado porque no te gusta tu trabajo
porque debes la casa porque chicos
enfermo y no tienes dinero para la
medicina a medio las personas tienen
problemas por estrés basado en eso en
que no hacen lo que les gusta
esta frase da gracias a áreas de la
pensión es un derecho sin deber porque
si no es feliz estás amargando a todo el
barrio muchas veces si tú estás amargado
no es capaz de compartir algo más
sociedad si no tienes algo no lo puedes
dar
tienes que vivir para ser feliz porque
principalmente parecen unos alumnos
cantinflas decía las dos principales
motivos de la vida es ser felices y
hacer felices a los demás y básicamente
no siento que eso se trata es mejor no
sé tomar un refresco en la esquina de tu
casa con una persona que realmente
aprecias con alguien que te agrada mucho
su compañía a irte de angelópolis con un
amigo que ni siquiera está amigo pero tú
tienes la plata para tamara y dos
estudios si estás bien con eso
pero realmente esta selva porque todos
van porque se está venir pero realmente
no te llenes si son muy pocos los amigos
con lo que realmente podéis tener una
apariencia más cercana y no tanto
dirigida a lo material
pero todo esto todo se resume a tener el
valor de hacer las cosas de no culpar a
nadie más por la vida que tu cultura
sino desplazarte de tomar las riendas de
tu propia vida así que aquí es dónde
viene la pregunta siguiente llega a
decir que es poder hacer esto si no
sabes hacer debes de contestar no creo
que sea tan difícil y esfuercito pro
lograrlo porque de eso se trata la
verdad esforzarte
esta empresa
[Música]